bonsoir et merci de nous avoir rejoint
pour ce premier journal de la semaine en
direct à 18h voici d'abord ce que l'on
peut retenir dans cette édition du lundi
22 décembre avant les médecins
généralistes et les spécialistes se sont
les urgences qui se sont mis en grève
aujourd'hui le pôle jeunesse de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux propose des
animations autour des addictions
jusqu'au 21 janvier nous avons suivi un
atelier auprès de collégiens de 6e et
nous en parlons dans quelques instants
avec nos invités changements à la tête
de la direction académique des Yvelines
après cinq ans Jean-Michel le Coignard
rejoint le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il revient sur ces années
passées dans le département et dresse un
bilan de son action mélodie marron tout
d'abord avec ce tragique accident de la
circulation survenue ce samedi soir vers
20h30 sur la D91 à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
en direction de Magny-les-Hameaux des
marques de police au sol des fragments
de carrosserie voilà ce qu'il reste de
la collision survenu entre une voiture
et un quart le passager de la voiture a
été tué dans l'accident 9 du pont du car
ont été choqués et légèrement blessés
trois équipes médicalisées se sont
rendus sur place ainsi que 35
sapeurs-pompiers on va maintenant on va
continuer on va parler santé nous allons
parler des addictions pour continuer ce
journal jusqu'au 21 janvier le pôle
jeunesse de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
consacre des ateliers et pour en parler
ce soir deux invités Ghislain bonsoir
vous êtes la responsable des ateliers au
sein du pôle jeunesse et Régis à Rennes
bonsoir vous êtes conseiller municipal
délégué à la jeunesse alors avant de
détailler avec vous c'est opérations je
vous propose de regarder ce reportage
nous sommes allés filmer un de ces
ateliers justement au collège Jacques
Cometti de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
vous suivez les pointillés vous passez
bien entre les plots et voilà vous
passez pas dessus n'hésitez pas à aller
doucement parce que ça va modifier votre
vision donc ça sert à rien de vous
précipiter un parcours à réaliser rien
de plus simple sauf que ces jeunes vont
être équipés de lunettes qui modifient
la vision et leur donne l'impression
d'avoir zéro grammed d'alcool par litre
de sang enfin pour vous ça
représenterait l'équivalent de deux ou
trois verres d'alcool vous arriveriez à
peu près à ce niveau là donc deux ou
trois verbes d'alcool parce que vous
n'avez pas du tout l'habitude de boire
et que vous êtes encore en pleine
croissance les effets sont immédiats des
marchés hésitantes clos déplacées
la sensation d'être
renversée un peu
comme si on allait tomber tout le temps
ça donne envie de vomir parce que on a
mal à la tête et
on a le vertige
ça est-ce que ça nous fait sur notre
corps le pôle jeunesse de la ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux existe depuis 4
ans et depuis 4 ans propose en accord
avec les établissements scolaires des
rencontres avec les jeunes le but ne
jamais culpabiliser ou formater un
discours mais plutôt libérer la parole
par des actions ludiques quand ils sont
très jeunes ils sont ils sont vraiment
dégoûtés par les produits la cigarette
qui trouve pas ça bon l'alcool non plus
et puis bah quelques années plus tard
malheureusement des fois il y en a qui
parlent d'autres par d'autres biais
comme on disait tout à l'heure
l'influence des autres ça joue beaucoup
le peur de pas être intégré au groupe
quand on va dire non donc du coup ils
ont peut-être tendance à consommer après
il y en a quand même qui garde leur
propre opinion et ça c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment très important on sent
bien ses forces des caractères comme ça
et puis c'est très bien aussi qu'il
puisse l'idée dans les interventions
c'est toujours qu'il le disent devant
les autres en fait parce que quand la
parole elle passe par nous c'est une
chose mais quand elle passe par eux
c'est encore mieux
alors les addictions comment résister à
la tentation c'est le nom de l'opération
qui se déroule jusqu'au 21 janvier par
le Pôle Jeunesse de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et les jasmin ont
vous entend dans ce dans ce reportage on
sent que suivant l'âge des enfants vers
qui vous vous tournez le discours n'est
pas le même oui bien sûr il y a une
différence qui est très marquée
notamment au collège en fait au début ce
sont encore presque des enfants donc ils
sont pas encore dans la consommation ils
n'ont pas envie ils trouvent pas ça bon
et puis au fur et à mesure ils avancent
ils ont envie comme tous les adolescents
de faire leur propre expérimentations et
de rejoindre le groupe surtout donc pour
s'identifier au groupe ils vont
peut-être avoir tendance à consommer
comment vous arrivez à libérer la parole
parce que c'est est-ce que le côté
ludique fait justement qui se libère un
peu et qui peuvent raconter un peu de
leur vie quotidienne bien sûr le côté
ludique quand on passe par le jeu ça
passe tout de suite beaucoup mieux et
puis le fait après de leur de leur
montrer qu'on n'est pas un professeur
qu'ils ont droit même si on respecte des
règles de s'exprimer en toute liberté
qu'on est là pour parler de ces sujets
là avec eux et que c'est une réelle
chance pour eux pour pouvoir s'exprimer
sur ce sur cette thématiques là ils ont
vraiment conscience du danger de ces
drogues des drogues en général ou des
addictions au tabac l'alcool alors
conscience du danger oui mais il pense
pas que ça les concerne eux c'est
toujours l'autre qui va risquer quelque
chose m'épanou en fait c'est plus cette
idée là qu'il faut arriver à leur faire
passer il a des collégiens comme ça de
6e on parle de quel addiction là on a vu
qu'on parlait de l'alcool on va plutôt
parler effectivement des produits comme
l'alcool le tabac peut-être un peu
évoqué le cannabis mais pas s'il évoque
pas eux-mêmes en fait eux-mêmes ils ont
déjà entendu parler de certains produits
mais on va plutôt aller vers l'alcool le
tabac la chicha qui sont des produits
auxquels ils peuvent avoir faire face au
quotidien on parle de la cigarette
électronique oui un petit peu ils en ont
entendu parler donc ils vont commencer à
l'évoquer là on vous a vu vous étiez au
collège Jacques que metty il y a aussi
d'autres collèges qui vont être
concernés à Montigny par ces ateliers
oui bien sûr cette année nous allons
aussi au collège des prés au mois de
janvier et puis le collège de La Coudre
en suivant puisqu'on a la chance de
pouvoir travailler avec tous les
établissements de la ville et notamment
les collèges c'est les collèges
dans les lycées pas dans les écoles
primaires parce que c'est trop tôt dans
les écoles primaires alors dans les
écoles primaires en tout cas ça concerne
pas le pôle jeunesse puisque le pôle
jeunesse à partir de 12 ans et dans les
lycées on va y aller mais plus dans la
dans la sur le dernier trimestre de
l'année mais on y va aussi pour faire
des interventions vraiment là dans les
classes là on a vu donc c'était
directement dans les classes mais il y a
aussi au pôle jeunesse des ateliers qui
sont menés jusqu'au 21 janvier qu'est-ce
qu'on peut y faire dans ce projet
jeunesse toujours un côté ludique
toujours un côté ludique oui puis c'est
vrai que le pôle jeunesse on a la chance
d'avoir un réel espace qui est très beau
très ludique avec un avion plein de
petits jeux à faire donc il y a toujours
le côté information avec l'exposition
mais d'autres outils que ce que l'on
peut proposer en animation et l'idée
t'ont toujours le même le prétexte de
l'animation pour après ouvrir le
dialogue alors vous ouvrez le dialogue
sur les addictions on a dit alcool tabac
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres addictions
dont vous parlez au pôle jeunesse on
pense aux jeux vidéos peut-être oui bien
sûr alors sur les jeux vidéo il y a pas
encore vraiment de consensus mais en
tout cas sur les pratiques excessives et
on essaye toujours de parler de bonnes
messages parce que on n'est pas
forcément sur l'addiction
l'avez pas encore de consensus qui a été
qui a été approuvé mais en tout cas on
peut parler de pratiquer excessive ça
c'est sûr donc non pour jeunesse qu'on
essaie de faire c'est toujours parler de
bonne utilisation de bon usages donc
évidemment cette thématique là elles
font aussi partie des sujets à abordés
on peut parler aussi de cannabis bien
évidemment un petit peu moins des autres
drogues comme la cocaïne ou les ruines
qui concerne un peu moins en tout cas
les jeunes que l'on peut voir au pot
jeunesse alors le pôle jeunesse existe
depuis 4 ans régissant quelle est la
mission de ce pôle qui accueille donc on
comprend les jeunes à partir de 12 ans
en fait il y a plein de missions en fait
sur le pôle jeunesse ça peut c'est déjà
une mission d'écoute une mission
d'information et puis après donc ils
peuvent trouver tout ça peut être pour
l'emploi ça peut être pour pour la santé
en fait il pose toutes les questions qui
veulent toutes les questions qui les
préoccupent en fait ça s'adresse à
quelques tranches de population de 12
ans et puis j'irai jusqu'à 25 on va à
peu près on n'a pas une limite une
limito en fait après c'est plutôt ça
peut tous les gens qui sont concernés
par l'université par les problèmes de
les transmissions sexuelles aussi pareil
de donc les maladies sexuellement
transmissibles donc tout ça tout est
abordé en fait alors il faut être
habitant de Montigny pour venir ou non
toutes les personnes qui passent devant
le pull jeunesse peuvent rentrer et on
ne demande pas ni car l'identité surtout
pas en fait c'est un animal total oui
c'est ça c'est gratuit et c'est anonyme
ça c'est important donc on peut venir
poser une question pas laisser son nom
rien
obtenir des réponses avec un accueil
confidentiel également et vous dites au
contraire parce que c'est important que
c'est important toujours de le préciser
de montrer qu'on n'est pas là pour juger
les gens mais pour vraiment leur
apporter une information qui compose le
pôle jeunesse en dehors de de vous
il y a deux autres personnes en fait qui
est parce que il peut jeunesse et aussi
le conseil municipal des jeunes qui
concerné par ça et puis il y a donc il y
a trois personnes qui composent le pôle
jeunesse donc à Éline il y a Stéphanie
Garraud la directrice et Mustapha qui
est le qui s'occupe plus du côté
justement conseil municipal déjà qui
vient d'été nouvellement élus là voilà
et une dernière question sur les sur je
reviens sur les addictions puisque c'est
la thématique du moment où Paul jeunesse
quels conseils on peut donner à un
parent qui peut-être aurait vu son
enfant consommer un peu d'alcool par
exemple vous fumer une cigarette pour le
bon mot à dire parce qu'il faut pas être
culpabilisant je crois mais trop
moralisateur malgré tout quand on mesure
l'angoisse des parents c'est ça mais je
pense que la chose la plus importante
mais comme dans beaucoup de domaines
c'est de montrer qu'on est ouvert au
dialogue qu'on est là pour les écouter
et que il y a d'autres personnes qui
n'ont pas aussi les jeunes n'ont pas
envie de parler alors parents qui sont
là pour les écouter mais en tout cas de
jamais rompre le dialogue qui est
toujours une forme de communication
très bien merci en tout cas vous doit
être sur le plateau du journal donc nous
parler à la fois du projet jeunesse et
donc de tout ce travail qui est fait
autour des addictions et ça sera
jusqu'au 21 janvier merci à vous deux
d'être venu on va continuer on va parler
éducation maintenant Jean-Michel
Coignard a été aura été directeur
académique pendant cinq ans dans les
Yvelines Amanda assez long il a quitté
ses fonctions vendredi dernier pour
rejoindre le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il nous a reçu quelques heures
avant de quitter son bureau pour nous
dresser un bilan de son action
bonsoir Jean-Michel Coignard vous
quittez vos fonctions après 5 ans en
qualité de directeur académiques des
Yvelines je vais rappeler brièvement
votre parcours vous êtes situé à un de
psychologie de sciences de la formation
vous avez exercé comme instituteur avant
de devenir en 92 inspecteur de
l'Éducation nationale vous avez fait un
crochet par le ministère de Xavier Darko
en tant que conseiller technique sport
handicap et santé scolaire c'était en
2008 vous vous en rappelez voilà et puis
il y a 5 ans vous êtes donc devenu
directeur académique des Yvelines là
vous quittez la direction pour rejoindre
à nouveau j'ai envie de le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale pour une mission
de 3 ans de quoi s'agit-il oui
en effet une nouvelle mission se
constitue auprès du secrétaire général
du ministère de l'Éducation
autour de la politique du haut
encadrement il s'agit en fait de faire
vivre les viviers de ceux qui
deviendront inspecteur d'académie ou
secrétaire général de l'Académie ou
encore
chef de service au ministère ou encore
directeur général de services en
université vous êtes arrivés à la
direction académique ici désigne il y a
5 ans 5 ans c'est pas mal ouais c'est un
bon mandat c'est rare 5 ans non les
inspecteurs d'académiques restent de
moins en moins longtemps en effet
le renouvellement est plus fréquent et
cinq ans c'est presque demanda en
général on fait un mandat de 3 ans ou
alors demande à 3 ans 6 ans moi je pars
presque à la fin du deuxième mandat
quand vous êtes arrivés il y a 5 ans
vous ne connaissiez pas les Yvelines
donc quel regard vous portiez sur ce
département et 5 ans après qu'elle
regarde où vous avez aussi quand je suis
arrivé je savais que c'était le plus
beau département de France pour
l'éducation nationale ou quelque chose
de voisin c'est à dire pourquoi le plus
beau il est connu comme le plus un des
plus gros
et les plus vivants et des plus beaux je
me suis enrichi de ce département au fil
des jours des mois et des cinq années
je suis frappé par la diversité humaine
et des paysages dans ce département puis
en même temps par le comment dire le
goût de le goût de la réussite de du
mouvement
et c'est vrai aussi pour l'éducation
nationale naturellement des grandes
caractéristiques c'est l'opposition
entre les secteurs ruraux
urbains riches et urbain défavorisé et
moi je trouve qu'en 5 ans on
s'améliorait partout en fait du point de
vue éducation nationale je sais que les
résultats des élèves se sont améliorés
globalement mais aussi dans chacun des
territoires
et puis bon j'ai apprécié aussi beaucoup
la diversité des personnes sur ce
territoire
j'appréciais les enseignants bien sûr
les élus je trouve que les élus sont
très préoccupés par l'éducation on a
fait plein de belles choses avec les
communautés d'agglo avec le Conseil
Général est-ce qu'il y a des dossiers
qui ont été partis particulièrement plus
compliqué que d'autres on pense
forcément au rythme scolaire mais ce qui
est le rythmmaire c'est l'actualité plus
récente de c'est un truc de court terme
quand même ça dure depuis deux ans en
enclenchait vraiment que cette année et
c'est un sujet qui sera de moyen terme
donc c'est un dossier que tu es
compliqué mais précisément avec les élus
avec avec les écoles avec les syndicats
avec les parents
au final malgré les oppositions
dans un esprit de responsabilité
finalement on a fait les choses c'est
quoi les qualités d'un bon directeur
académique c'est à la fois avoir de la
souplesse de la pédagogie de l'écoute je
présume
moi je crois après avoir fait ça avec
passion de longues années maintenant
je crois qu'en fait on a tout d'abord
aucun pouvoir réel en vacances c'est
celui que les autres vous donnent c'est
vrai qu'on en a matériellement
concrètement mais ça sert à rien moi je
pense que le boulot il est sur le il est
vraiment sur l'encouragement
la rencontre elle encouragement des
personnes donc faut donner confiance à
tout le monde il faut toujours être
positif il faut dire que tout le monde
fait du bon travail et le montrer il
faut dire que les élèves sont des
pépites on dit passé c'est tout le monde
noir si tout mais il faut montrer qu'on
a des résultats et c'est vrai dans les
Yvelines burna j'ai oublié de dire que
dans les années où j'étais là on avait
progresser les résultats des élèves de
façon étonnante alors évidemment on voit
l'excellence sur les territoires ou les
familles sont plus favorisés de manière
très très forte avec des mentions encore
plus grande que vous avez passé mais sur
les terrains territoires plus
défavorisés je donne un exemple parmi
d'autres on a on a doublé le taux
d'accès au baccalauréat dans les
quartiers des favoris en bref il faut à
mon avis faire essayer d'être influent
ramener tout le temps tout le monde à
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est qu'on est
là pour les autres on est là pour les
enfants et que globalement ça doit se
faire avec une confiance dans l'avenir
et puis beaucoup de modestie d'humour de
distance et voilà c'est un boulot de
l'humanité c'est il y a 30 000 personnes
qui travaillent autour des enfants et
des plus jeunes dans les ducs dans les
départements
donc faire des circulaires c'est bien
mais en fait faut plutôt être très doué
à mon avis et puis être directif parfois
mais surtout leur donner confiance dans
ce qu'ils font je crois que c'est
essentiel même chose avec les élus il
faut jamais oublier qu'on n'est pas tout
seul et son national c'est une des
compétences majeure certes mais on la
partage avec les mères les conseils
généraux le conseil régional et là aussi
il faut être convaincant certes mais il
faut travailler avec voilà ça fait déjà
deux angles d'attaque sur ce métier
particulier parmi les beaux sujets qu'on
a eu il y a tout ce qui concerne
l'éducation prioritaire donc c'est
d'actualité la carte vient d'être revue
moi je suis heureux des résultats qu'on
a pu obtenir c'est pas moi qui les
obtiens j'ai juste aidé ce qu'ils
arrivent dans les différents sites on va
avoir un peu plus de moyens sur certains
territoires en éducation prioritaire
grâce à la réforme il faudra pousser les
feux je vous disais tout à l'heure on a
doublé l'accès au bac calauréat des
enfants de ces quartiers non ça suffit
pas encore poursuivre et faire mieux
dans le domaine de ceux qui ont le moins
de chance il y a les décrocheurs
je trouve qu'on a fait un gros travail
en montant d'abord parce qu'elle
n'existait pas les plateformes de
prévention du décrochage et de
traitement des décrocheurs et on voit
aujourd'hui les résultats que l'on
récupère c'est pas vrai qu'on les laisse
tomber donc je vois qu'on a multiplié
par deux ce que l'on rattrape avec les
plateformes et puis après il y a des
choses
réjouissantes comme tout ce qu'on fait
dans le domaine des arrêts de la culture
ou en 5 ans
par deux ou trois nos partenariats un
petit regret quand même c'est le
numérique
on n'a pas pu la signer donc on n'a pas
pu progresser autant que je le
souhaitais mais enfin les débuts sont là
je sais que ça se poursuivra moi j'ai
équipé par exemple tous les formateurs
des écoles départements des enseignants
de matériel cette année je pars alors
qu'on a réussi à avoir pas mal de
moyens pour faire ce qu'on appellera des
ambassadeurs du numérique au fait sont
des profs
mieux formés que d'autres qui
emporteront
leurs vidéosprojecteur portatif partout
où ils seront donc voilà ça à suivre
mais
entre le retard des fois l'allumage
c'est pour être meilleur à l'arrivée
quand vous dites à suivre donc c'est
pour c'est peut-être le message adressé
à votre successeur qui a déjà été nommé
il s'agit de Serge Clément il arrive de
la de la loi de Saint-Étienne là je
présume que la transition est en train
de se faire de s'opérer et du coup c'est
quoi le conseil que Jean-Michel
Coignières peut donner un Serge Clément
je peux le dire en public comme je lui
ai dit je lui ai dit la première chose
c'est d'essayer de rester dans une un
esprit d'ouverture et d'aller voir les
les pépites qu'il y a dans département
passons fermer dans son bureau et faire
le techno on a un super équipement
techno technique là avec tous les
collègues qui travaillent respectueux
académique non il faut être dehors il
faut aller voir les personnes il faut
avoir un esprit de projet je lui ai dit
beaucoup ça puis le reste le reste c'est
juste de la connaissance il y en a plein
des placards là ça on le découvre et
puis on l'apprend petit à petit merci
voilà pour l'entretien avec Jean-Michel
Coignard réalisé et vendredi dernier les
urgentistes en grève ce lundi partout en
France y compris dans les Yvelines et
praticiens hospitalières réclament une
réduction du temps de travail à 48
heures hebdomadaires contre une
soixantaine actuellement ainsi que la
valorisation de leurs heures
supplémentaires au date 39 heures un
mouvement initié par la MUF
l'Association des médecins urgentistes
de France une mobilisation forte près de
80% de ses médecins ont répondu à
l'appel en France c'était également le
cas dans le département aux urgences de
Versailles ou encore celle de
Rambouillet ou 100% des praticiens était
en grève un mouvement toutefois sans
conséquence pour les passions puisque
les urgences sont réquisitionnés pour le
fonctionnement du service
pour le public et les patients il y a
peu d'implication puisque tous les
urgentistes sont assignés pour venir
travailler donc les urgences sont
assurées la Rev
endication fait que les
le nombre d'heures travaillées
dans les services d'urgence soit 39
heures
et voir des heures supplémentaires ce ne
soit pas sur des heures de soins et
qu'elles soient payées il y a aussi des
revendications d'ajustement sur les
gardes pour que les gares soient payés
quel que soit le statut de la même façon
c'est principal revendications
aujourd'hui pour les médecins gentils et
les cadres de la mue font effectivement
continuer les discussions avec les
ministères il faut que l'ensemble comme
dans tout mouvement syndical il faut que
l'ensemble des représentants du syndicat
se met d'accord il y aura de nouveau ce
soir un conseil administration et demain
matin une assemblée générale ou au vu de
la décision de l'ensemble
les gens diront oui on accepte ces
premières avancées ou non pour continuer
le mouvement de rêve
voilà donc on saura demain si le
mouvement ou non est maintenu chez ses
médecins urgentistes et dans un sondage
publié ce matin 63% des Français étaient
solidaires du mouvement alors vous
justement comprenez vous le mouvement
des urgences c'est notre question du
jour oui je comprends la grève des
urgentistes
ils ne sont pas suffisamment payés par
rapport à tout ce qu'ils font et la
fatigue doit
gêner leur travail je pense qu'ils ont
besoin de meilleure organisation à leur
travail je pense que c'est pas au sujet
des salaires pas seulement c'est sûr
avec les horreurs qui font je pense que
c'est un peu rock'n'roll quoi mais ça
risque d'avoir des incidences sur les
soins tout ça tout ça ce sont des
dossiers un peu compliqués qui qui
remettent en cause mon taux
d'organisation du système des soins et
donc je pense que le problème c'est
qu'il y a pas eu de réflexion globale au
niveau gouvernemental pour organiser ces
trois photos de soins et donc tant qu'on
n'aura pas refait cette remise à plat je
pense qu'on aura toujours les problèmes
de ce type là
allez on change totalement de sujets
connaissez-vous le scrapbooking c'est un
loisir créatif de plus en plus tendance
un mélange entre bricolage décoration et
création il s'adresse aux petits comme
au grand à l'Office de Tourisme de 50
ans en Yvelines les ateliers gratuits
sont proposés aux enfants Florent
parfait Élodie moine
là je vous donne les consignes et après
on va bricoler ensemble ça elle est
carré mousse relief c'est facile du
papier cartonné quelques strasses et du
scotch mais avant tout il faut des mains
agiles et de l'imagination pour faire du
scrapbooking c'est ce que nous confie
Valérie Madier animatrice et gérante de
l'atelier de colle le scrapbooking ça
veut dire faire avec des petits bouts
faire des albums un peu avec tout ce
qu'on trouve ça vient un peu des
navigateurs qui faisaient des albums de
bord en fait avec tout ce qui pouvait
trouver au cours de leur voyage et là
l'idée c'est de soit faire des albums
photos d'embellir des photos de mettre
en scène des photos soit de réaliser de
la carte riz justement aujourd'hui c'est
une carte que les enfants doivent
réaliser Valérie leur montre un modèle
les étapes et la machine à découpe pour
confectionner leurs œuvres même les plus
petits s'en sortent bien
j'ai trouvé un truc
le mot Noël et là je vais tous les
des
paillettes pour pour faire le
trémor on crée des choses et du coup on
peut les envoyer à nos amis à nos
nos papiers mamie et tout ça à l'origine
c'est un loisir créatif à destination
des adultes créés il y a une dizaine
d'années aux États-Unis ça reste ça
reste en vrai développement actuellement
et surtout dans une période où les gens
ont besoin de se faire plaisir et de
réaliser des choses par eux-mêmes le
scrabooking un jeu d'enfant qui plaît au
grand il suffit juste de s'y coller
joli la fin allez du sport pour
continuer avec l'exploit du week-end
c'est peu de le dire c'est en couple de
France de basket et cela s'est passé du
côté de Maurepas le Petit Poucet
d'excellence à éliminer l'ogre de
national du tour de Coupe de France 3
divisions des cas entre les deux clubs
dans un gymnase de La malmedone vous le
voyez sur ces images plein à craquer les
morts pasiens partaient avec 20 points
d'avance en raison de l'écart de 3
divisions grâce à une défense très
agressive les joueurs d'Eure-et-Loir
remontent rapidement leur handicap à la
mi-temps Barjouville basculant tête avec
un point d'avance mais c'était
évidemment sans compter sur l'ambiance
dans le gymnase et la magie de la Coupe
de France le suspense va durer jusqu'à
la dernière minute à 22 secondes du
buzzer la défense du BCM tient bon et
obtient une dernière possession pour
repasser devant et souffrir la victoire
Maurepas s'impose 89 à 87 est réussi le
plus grand exploit de son histoire en
Coupe de France
c'est indescriptible sincèrement qui
aurait pu miser une pièce sur nous mais
bon voilà c'est c'est un groupe qui
travaille dur toute la saison on est
invaincu en championnat c'est qu'une
récompenses une récompense par rapport à
tout ce qu'on travaille depuis 3 ans
voilà si vous voulez continuer à vibrer
avec les mots repasiens ne manquez pas
dans quelques instants le 7 8 sport
Anthony Reich reçoit le président et
l'entraîneur de ce club de basket voilà
ce qu'on pouvait dire dans cette édition
du 22 décembre merci de votre attention
rendez-vous demain en direct à 18h d'ici
là bonne soirée